my name is dasha converse sky I work for
Wolfram research on the probability and
statistics team and I would like to talk
a bit now about time series the abstract
is very straightforward it tells me only
that I need to magnify so this is not
the first talk and the time series
function I mean about time series and
temporal data and Wolfram language and
this is not a new object in invoke from
language and so I am taking some
liberties you actually show you some
examples and case you know case studies
maybe but examples on different ways to
use these objects and also how to use
different processing functions about
that no good please come forward I mean
the only thing I can do is to make the
whole thing 150 then it's not gonna fit
on the screen so that's a table to
summarize kind of what we have so color
tells you we have time serious event
serious temporal data although the head
for all the subject is temporal data I
know it's a kind of confusing thing but
there is a way to work around it and and
kind of keep track of what is what so
there are differences between each of
the each of these objects and the main
that like few main things that I put
here time series in event series are a
single path objects only while temporal
data allows you to to store multiple
paths when we query an object at the
given time stamp the time series in
event series will return a value while
temporal data will return data
distribution I will show example for
that too then the question is what
happens when you queried an object in
between the existing timestamps and you
can the time series were interpolate
the event series will not impact
interpolate not return missing and
temporal data will also in calculate in
a way that it's older it will be zero so
it just returns the previous value also
known as hold from the left so first I'm
going to talk about time series usually
used to store some physical quantities
and I have an example here about you
know the length of the daylight we have
fall the shorter it makes me depressed
so I think about these things we can
have a property of the Sun the daily
time above the horizon and today this is
10 hours 58 minutes yesterday it was 11
hours so the days are getting shorter in
it and you can see that I can have some
dated so I can have this properties you
know at any kind of given time and
because this is astronomical computable
property I can have it in the future I
can have it in the past because that's
that's computed and so what I did here I
computed a time series for the whole
2018 and this comment that code is this
is how I did it but I don't want to kind
of reproduce that so I just had the time
series and also this notebook will be
available on the puffer ball so you can
always you know all about this for for
itself and so we have the time series
the property first Vario gives me you
know exactly what it says first value so
that's 9 hours 13 minutes so more or
less the first of January length of the
day first date though when you look
carefully it is first of January but
what it tells you which here it tells
you nineteen hundred's and when you look
at the creation of the time series is
that I didn't really provide dates to be
specified the timestamps to be specified
for the folder for this for this time
series and when you look whether they
actually have dates they don't so what
happened here is that all this
information about the length of the day
is stored in terms of integers so just
enumerated observations but this is not
completely you know lost case because we
can
rescale the time series to put dates in
on the time stamps so take the time
series to scale apply to the existing
time series and just you know give the
starting date the ending date and then
the step in which we would like to
rescale our you know time series and
then we have dates where where first
date is really January 2019 as you can
see and and so we're we have fixed the
timestamps the other thing is that as
you all noticed the day light was given
in a mixed units hours and minutes maybe
this is not the best we can also apply
unit convert over the whole time series
to change to hours then the first value
is just some you know fraction value in
in terms of hours we can compute the
mean and then we can plot you know this
time series using the date at least plot
to see how the day light is the length
of the day is changing right another
case that it's also popular it's the
financial data so the thing is that when
we do the day trading the price of the
stock is not changing from day to day
orally so especially when you have a
closing price or or an opening you know
price nothing is changing so we would
make more sense to actually use temporal
data but because we are also interested
in accessing the values on a given time
stamp it may be more adventure may be
better to actually use time series but
change the interpolation you know like
the data sampling so we don't really
have the you know the linear
interpolation which is the default for
the time series so this is a some stock
probably some computer company are being
traded and you kind of see the plot and
what I have here it's the date path and
this is the first five observations and
so what we can see that this is
Wednesday it's use Wednesday Thursday
Friday and the next one is Monday right
so the point is that the the sampling
time
well as the time series were created is
just linear interpolation so if I ask
what is the value on Saturday so January
5th I'm gonna get value which is
interpolated between Friday and Monday
right and we know that nothing nothing
changed so the way to go around it is to
find new time series taking into
argument our existing time series and
just resetting there a sampling method
to hold from the left and then when you
take this closing and queries on the on
Saturday we gonna get the same value as
there wasn't Friday the 34 point 48 so
that solves the the interpolation and
yet we always get the value on a given
of a given date another issue that we
kind of see with this time series these
objects is that the trading happens on
business days not on the days that's
what we just saw there was no
information for Saturday and Sunday and
so when you look now at this at this new
time series that
just-just-just result just holes from
the left still this is not a regularly
sampled object that means that they're
different the difference is between time
stamps are not the same and when you
look at the minimum time increment it
gives you one day because yes between
Monday and Tuesday it's one day but we
really should think about business days
for this type of data and there are two
ways to kind of fix I'm serious one of
that is to redefine time series so I
take the time series take the values
define then this is important bit here
define the new range for the time stamps
when our step is by business day okay
and another important bit here is to
specify holiday calendar okay so we know
this business days are according to you
know the proper stock exchange if these
are the stocks you know and such so we
go from language with some of the
trading holiday calendars and I would
like to point out that this is no
equivalent to the federal united states
holiday calendar the holidays are
different so that's one way and another
way is to basically use the time series
for example that looks nothing easier on
the ice by business days and also
important bit specified the New York
Stock Exchange holiday calendar and then
when you see the the the increment the
minimum increment is no business day
they are regularly sampled in both cases
and what is important the puff didn't
change so when you look at just the
dates and this is exactly the same as we
started and yet we know that this series
is regularly sampled and we also know
that it keeps the value from the left
and when when when we have the the
regularly sample time series then we can
actually trust the the estimation the
modeling and so this is applying the
time series model fit to one of the
sampled time series when you do this
with the original data that was not
regularly sampled you're gonna get this
nice information that we are sampling
this for you
but you really have no control how and
in a way but you see the information
that's it is sampled at the resolution
of the minimum time increment and you
know it was a day not a business day so
that may be not what you want for your
data these are the models you can see
that the model - because it was so
example on the day we'll have you know
put in Saturday and Sundays and so what
is interesting is to kind of have a
forecast the trend and when you when you
model the you know the the sample data
it actually models at the forecast in
business days when you forecast the non
sample data that that was real sampling
to every single day it's gonna give you
forecast in terms of steps that are days
so that's something to keep in mind okay
event series this is this is a bit
lighter stuff and because what we can do
we can have various values of most
anything in the world even in in time
series but especially for the event
series
so this is event series of the birthdays
of American presidents and she actually
got this example right I had to learn
some trivia we currently have the 45th
president but there were only 44
presidents because Grover Cleveland was
a president twice but not in a
consecutive terms and when he became a
president again that he had a new number
that's why our numbering system it's not
in agreement with the number of human
beings that served this office so what
we can do to you spatter this event
series one thing is to use time line
plot you can see the dates so the
presidents were born we can also use
this time line plot with our association
fret to have the values and dates and
then it gives you this nice thing here
telling you when who when was was born
what I find interesting from the
statistical point of view is the birth
day distribution within the year and
that histogram of the data reduction
it's really cool for that and it works
just directly on the event series and
you see that people born in September
have really low chances and I was born
in September and it was crushing was
also not born in this country but it's a
different story and another fun kind of
fun factoids that we can do especially
if the event series is to work with
dates again but I was talking at the
dates when things givings happened and
we know that Thanksgiving now is on
Thursday but that was not always the
case and also having some you know data
know that you know in encoding from
language you can actually access some
interesting information so the first
year it happened was 1619 again my
commented out code is a query to vote
from alpha do you actually extract all
the dates for the for the for the things
givings and then I just get the event
series and the thing is that the time
stamps are actually the the exact dates
one of thanksgiving happen but the
values is the number
which is the year and when you plot this
on a timeline plot it kind of looks
continuous because this is a lot of
points so again what can we do to kind
of analyze this this data byte better
these days
so again they'd histogram with date
reduction reduction in a week tells us
yes Thursday is the dominating day of
the week but Thanksgiving without the
pie it's not complete so what I did here
is to you do use a time series map
thread which allows us to apply function
on the timestamps and so to take the
date value which is over the time stamp
which is the day name and so I have a
new event series which basically will
just have values which are the names of
the of the week days Tuesday Sunday and
when we tally the values we can see how
many how many times don't inch given day
the film is giving happen and that's my
favorite thing the PI so can see that
yes first day dominates and the other
thing what we can do is to you gather
now the week that you know like this is
the week that event series based on the
based on the exactly the weekday and
then sort that by the weekday and in
that way I create kind of seven seven
feeds in in that way or I can say and
clothe again on the timeline plot that
each data feed is for a for a given day
of the week and so I think that the
first day establish itself at the end of
the or during the civil war
another interesting trivia and then so
how many there is between Thanksgivings
another application of the moving map
and can plot a histogram and then 13
more days this year
okay temporal data as I mentioned the
beginning temporal data on a given
timestamp query returns data
distribution because the the original
design for the temporal data was to
store simulations of the random
processes and so random process in
question we're really a time series
processes just like here is this arma
process and when you evaluate random
function so get a simulation it gives us
a single path and this is stored as a
temporal data and in simulation world we
sometimes want to simulate more than
just one path so we have more
observation so either five and if you
have more paths like here we have a
thousand paths right we can do some
statistics for you know like slicing the
the path at a given time stamp so the
slice distribution will be exactly
accessing the temporal data at time 10
so this is this is exactly the what
happens when you query at the given time
stamp we get the data distribution we
can compute the mean of this
distribution and we can plot for example
CDF we can also get sliced data that's
the property you get you know the the
sliced data and it's gonna be at least
and this list will have a thousand
elements because we had thousand paths
so kind of slice in that way and what we
can do we can plot a histogram for this
slice data and we can study the
distribution for a given for a given
time
okay so there if you don't have the same
time stamps you can still put it
together in one object of temporal data
this is okay because they don't the
number of how to say the number of paths
so I need to have enough like the same
amount of values and the same amount of
a timestamp so they can they are
marching yes exactly so that so so what
I'm saying that if you have this this
multiple path that they don't have the
matching timestamps and if you query
something at the given time what happens
is that that you're gonna get it either
interpolated you cannot get interpolated
value and if this is temporal data and
only temporal data allows multiple paths
you're gonna have the value hold from
the from the left so it's gonna fill the
fill the blanks if you don't kind of you
don't have the exact timestamps it just
gonna give you the previous value it's
automatically but you as a user of
temporal data can change that behavior
so that is controlled by there a
sampling method and you can put
different order it can be linear
temporal data can interpolate linearly
quadratically it can return missing and
that's that's that's full flexibility
there yes
no I have this is maybe a bit more
technical issue but it's I think it's
important it's about the sampling and I
mentioned this a bit already in the
previous examples this is a time series
of four four values ABCD and four types
which are given explicitly one three
four four and a half and so you can see
that this is not regularly sampled and
regularly sampled q is the top level
function that can tell you but also
there is a property called uniformly
spaced queue
among the properties that they can also
give you this information about the
uniform sampling this is this this list
of properties is called developer
properties and it's called this for a
reason because most mortal human beings
don't need all of them and is kind of
flexible as I add stuff as I need and
might actually promote some of those
into the proper properties but for
people who are using and want to have
finer control of the temporal die
talking this is useful to know that all
of this is available how one of the
things that in this you know from this
lease the property that tells you a lot
about well the time stamps is the so
called unexpanded throw times and in
this way we'll see that because our time
stamps are not regular they could it be
pocketing in a nice range we have to
keep all the lists you know together if
I take this new time series here which
is which is just regular times two years
the same values but starts at zero and
automatically will have the times zero
one two three and when you when you
compare an expanded row x over the times
you see that they're different and then
expanded row times are actually stored
in a form of a range and the step and
and this is also a quick comparison of
the default sampling methods so time
series events 3 is temporal data exactly
the same values exactly the same time
stamps and then the sampling with
respect to the minimum time increment
and then basically see what happens
linear interpolation for the time series
in missing for the event series or a
holding the value from the left for the
temporal data this is as far going
consequences if you want to use
accumulated differences on any filters
coming from the signal processing okay
because all this you see that what I
have here it's accumulate on the time
series and get the values or accumulate
just the values and gonna see the
differences because accumulate and and
and and differences assume that that
things are regularly kind of fed to them
so require them to be in
in regular steps and I think I'm a
little bit more time so this is this is
to kind of let people know that this
gonna happen and and that's why having
the being aware of what's your
assembling matter is it's very important
and also whether you're gonna feed the
whole time serious temporal data into
dysfunction or only operate on values
right and one more thing is about the
missing data method because what happens
in real world is that we often get the
data in this case this is a weather data
feed temperature I get the time series
already from the weather data and now
the question is you know do I know if I
have missing or no do I have all the
values so how to find out well when we
plot them we kind of see the holes
there's some holes here on the plot but
like the really really fast way to do it
is to compute the mean because the mean
will tell you that it has missing in it
and it's not gonna be really meaningful
okay and their their waste you deal with
that and I'm gonna show you fuel and we
can create new time so you create new
time series object with the existing
time series object specifying missing
data method and in this way I am feeling
all the missing with a constant pi right
this is again not very meaningful I'm
not saying it makes sense for this data
but it's an example make sense for some
other in other cases so it's 300 price
we know we had 300 missing okay we can
also specify automatic okay and then for
from language will do it for you this is
the the way that the missing is filled
is is the same way as their a sampling
type specified so if there is a missing
than the automatic missing the tomatoes
were interpolate and for the time series
going to be linear interpolation so if I
do it directly like that specify missing
the a tomato does interpolation with
order one I get exactly the same mean as
the automatic method we can use
different interpolation method
interpolation order it'll be two they
mean changes a bit we can also
use moving map in a way to replace all
the missing with the mean of the non
missing values and get the meaningful
mean or delete all the missing from the
from the time series and then we got
exactly the kind of the same mean
because that was computed by the mean of
the non missing values and so and I am
done here so thank you very much
[Applause]